yo what's up everybody its procedure man
Luigi with some Borderlands the
pre-sequel gameplay in the first of many
legendary guides we're going to be
looking at all the legendaries in the
game and trying to get every single one
so the for this one is the quick hyphen
something thingy it is a corrosive
rocket launcher it is skava branded
consumes three mo every shot and it's
red text is somebody ain't what they
appear to be this is a pretty good
corrosive rocket launcher I do enjoy
using it now the reason it is a
legendary what makes it so special and
awesome and legendary is that when you
shoot it it shoots out a corrosive
projectile and it explodes on impact
splash damage that's pretty good splash
damage and except after it explodes in
hits an enemy it spawns multiple homing
grenades homing corrosive grenades that
seek out more enemies find and kill
those enemies so it's you shoot once and
then it get a lot more shots a lot more
than three projectile per each shot one
thing I must say it does run edit of
ammo fairly quickly especially because
as a mag size of oh this one has 10 so I
can shoot every bullet in there and it
will use up all my rocket launcher ammo
now we're going to get into how you find
it where to find it so first thing
you're going to want to do is you're
going to want to hop over to a quick
travel station a fast travel station
faster position and you're going to go
to serenity wastes now see Serena DS
waste is the first one of the first
places you actually go when you leave
Helios it is the first place that's
where he crash-land so you're going to
head on back there and you're gonna find
a secret raid boss you're gonna i'm
going to show you here where you go
you're probably get a stingray or
stingray works the best for this you can
do it without a singer a but a stingray
makes it a lot easier so you're gonna
leave the garage just kind of make a big
right u-turn and go to the lava lake
river and you're just gonna boost up the
waterfall you can do waterful lava ville
you can do this uh without a stingray
but you can jet pack from
not jet pack a oz glide from above but
it is a lot easier with the Stingray you
see on the map this is where I'm going
into entities waste that's where you
spawn and you go around a amid a little
area don't watch the mouse there you go
around and to where my character is that
I'll show if you follow the mouse cursor
I think I show yeah you can jump to this
ledge excuse me you can jump to that
ledge from above if you pull up to the
rights of this so you're going to keep
going you're going to go in here avoid
lava sins you don't want to get burned
and you're gonna hop down a hole and
then that's where your braid balls is
going to be at his name is hard to
pronounce I don't have it with me so
when it comes on the screen will both
see it but this area really is serves
only to spawn this guy this is really
good for the SEO there is I'm not going
to try and pronouncing his name this is
really good for once you finish it on
the game on Normal difficulty you can
farm him a bunch of times and to be
ready to go into true vault hunter mode
this is he's pretty like when you're
level 32 which is that's I be in the
game that was a good deal after i beat
the game but really it's that's close to
beating the game you beat the game
around level 28 the first time through
so it definitely makes sense that you're
around this level he's probably one of
the easier raid bosses in this game I
haven't faced a lot of raid bosses in
this game but he's probably one of the
easier ones since he really doesn't do
much damage even being within two levels
of you I know he's not there usually two
levels up but yeah so if you go into
this in true vault hunter mode it's
going to be a lot harder disease always
going to be a little 50 so if you're a
good level you can always just stick
through it and kill them you won't need
to use many tactics if I'd say just jump
around a lot use the jetpack and say to
the ground and I think you should see
pretty soon the drop and also you saw
what comes up here when you kill him you
get that little way to get out there's a
legendary you get that way to get out
you break the rock it'll boost you but
up and out of the area that you're in so
you see I got the rocket launcher the
quick change thingy i actually ended up
getting another rocket launcher from him
so we
has a pretty good drop rate of the quick
thingies I'm assuming that's what the
name is going to be so i farmed him ten
times and I got two of them so you
definitely will be able to get it from
him proof fairly easy well I guess maybe
I could have gotten super lucky but
honestly I think it's pretty easy to get
he's a pretty easy kill and by the way
he drops tons of moonstone I get at
least 20 moonstone every single time I
fight so this is gonna be the little
gameplay you're gonna get to see me miss
miss the guy twice and you see get the
kill and these go around and kill the
other enemies so that I can't even shoot
them there are three guys that spawned
that area and I only had to shoot one of
them even though I use three shots it's
a day like I said I'm facing enemies
that are weaker than me as significantly
but it still does pretty good work I
wouldn't say it's like super fantastic
since I fought some guys uh uh more to
my level up to par and it was it did it
did well but I don't know I think it'd
be good for a lot of crowd control and
maybe obviously since it's corrosive
it'll be better than against a lot of
armor however i don't think you like in
my opinion you do not fight that much
harder in this game like especially in
Borderlands 2 you fought a lot more
armor so this gun would have been a lot
more useful in that game in this game
but I still think it's a fun gun it's a
really easy to get gun that might be
good come some grind your recipes maybe
they call for like any legendary that
this would do well in I think that that
it'll be very good in that you see this
is one of the corrosive non-corrosive
armor enemies that we do see and
obviously it's a lower level so it took
it out pretty fast but even still it's a
good it's a really good weapon and now
you see I got the that's the second
rocket launcher that I was talking about
the quick smart thingy said basically
everything is the same its level lower
so it's a little bit weaker and also the
back of it uh is a little different in
the actual model like the other one had
like a handle in the back this just has
a tube so this one doesn't have the
minus sixty percent chain put weapon put
down because it's not the quick chain
it's the just quick smart and I'm I'm
kind of thinking quick smart is the
average since there's no other effect
that I can see so and a quick change
only has that plus minus sixty percent
effect so I think that's going to be it
and so yeah that's that's basically the
quick hyphen something thingy maybe a
quick smart thingy hope you guys have
all enjoyed this make sure to be on the
lookout since I'm going to be doing that
I definitely a lot more legendary guys
like you see I got the long nail I
believe it's called the rough I fire
incendiary sniper rifle I'm going to be
definitely doing some of that so make
sure you keep posted and yeah thanks for
watching